[Music]  a mural honoring tina tintor and her dog  max is now finished it was done near the  intersection where she was killed in the  west valley that crash happened back in  november police say former raider henry  ruggs was driving more than 100 miles an  hour when he caused that wreck tina's  family hopes the artwork serves as a  reminder to the community  they should remind them what can happen  in the second  to not be responsible and you know  especially drive  over the limit and three times over the  limit  and i don't think that's a good choice  and if somebody won a race they should  go in the racetrack and  try the luck over there  henry ruggs facing four felony charges  in this crash